les productions horticoles demers vont
construire d'ici la fin de l'année
le plus gros complexe de serres de la
province à lévis un projet de 70
millions en partie financé par québec
mais les consommateurs saft il dans
quelles conditions vivent de nombreux
gratte et maltais qui récolte les
tomates à drummondville
on vit un par dessus l'autre nous
manquons classe c'est inconfortable
alertés par plusieurs travailleurs
étrangers nous nous rendons sur place et
nous montre la présence de moisissures
sur les murs leur chambre où ils
s'entassent sait si le peu de rangement
cet homme dans avec sa valise les
installations vétustes et ils se
plaignent de l'inaction de leur syndicat
fait éprouvante à l'eau d'or unique a
été adjointe aux ressources humaines à
drummondville jusqu'en septembre dernier
moment où elle a été congédié la suite
de friction avec son employeur j'avais
mon corps blessé sérieusement note de
passage off et yeux c'est dur mais là et
ça me fait mal encore au tout début de
la pandémie monica raconte que vingt
travailleurs étrangers ont été
contraints de quitter leurs logements
nouveaux lieux désignés par l'entreprise
pour une quarantaine
conséquence certains ont dormi au sous
sol alors que d'autres ont vécu dans un
salon comment l'intérêt presse à
faissault comme enquête souvient l'un
fait les travailleurs comme des cochons
qui dort à terre pour tous c'était
difficile pour aller aux toilettes pour
cuisiner pour dormir
nous sommes dans un pays développé
je ne pensais pas que c'était possible
hellman et d'ariane ont tous deux briser
leur contrat l'année dernière parce
qu'il n'en pouvait plus ce n'est pas le
traitement correct qu'ils font aux
travailleurs au téléphone le grand
patron jacques demers se dit très
surpris il a d'abord refusé de nous
rencontrer nous référons conseillers en
ressources humaines qui a réfuté en bloc
plusieurs allégations l'extérieur
la csst a reçu deux plaintes la plus
récente en février concernant la
salubrité
le dossier a ensuite été signalés
rapidement à service canada et à la
santé publique qui mènent leur enquête
ça m'a choqué parce que de façon
générale c'est pas comme ça que les
terres agricoles sont hébergés quelque
temps lui est acquis
ministre fédéral et provincial de
l'agriculture se disent troublés
je suis horrifié franchement là les
travailleurs dans tous les secteurs
doivent être traités avec respect après
la publication notre enquête jacques
demers accepte finalement de nous
rencontrer
on pense que oui effectivement il ya de
l'amélioration et à y avoir et on va s'y
mettre
très rapidement on a déjà commencé le
pdg assure qu'il visitera les logements
de ses employés bientôt et qu'ils seront
logés dans de meilleures conditions ici
natacha lavigne radio-canada drôme ville